what a lot of people don't know is that
nobody's actually
looking at these bills nobody's actually
analyzing this bill before it gets paid
and before it gets sent on to you
these claims spit out yeah are auto
adjudicated
by a system that's processing millions
of claims a day
spitting things out computers are auto
adjudicating these things
there are strategies that the hospitals
are using
to up code your claims which means they
are
inflating the complexity of the medical
codes they use so that they can charge
more
but it's not justified in fact it's
fraudulent if they're willfully doing
that it's fraudulent
the system is also incredibly sloppy
errors that show up in the bills or
inflated prices or costs
necessitate each of us realizing oh wait
this bill let's assume it's not accurate
before we just assume it's accurate
let's assume it's not accurate
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to your next episode of
yang speaks
on the future of we're talking about the
future of medical bills today which
doesn't sound that sexy but i promise
it's probably the most practical thing
we've ever done on this podcast i'm zach
browman
i was andrew yang's campaign manager
during his presidential run and now
hosting our special series every
thursday on our future
and look today's guest is a guy named
marshall allen he's the author of the
book
never pay the first bill and it's
literally a
how-to guide on how to avoid
your insurance companies and your
medical billing
collectors whoever is billing you for
medical payments
how to avoid getting stuck paying
more than you're supposed to and you are
going to be blown away with how often
that happens it's happened to me it's
happened to carly
it's happened to a bunch of people been
on this podcast before so i want you
guys to tune in marshall allen
author of never pay the first bill
joins yang speak to teach us how to
avoid paying too much to these medical
companies
tune in learn about the future right now
[Music]
it is my privilege to welcome to yang
speaks the future
of reporter and author
of his newest book never pay the first
bill
i want to talk about the future of
health care and basically how you
navigate the health care system
welcome to yank speaks marshall allen
how are you sir
thank you zach i am excited to be here
i'm really excited to talk about this
with you
this topic is a person a basic personal
interest to me
because basically since i've i used to
work on wall street and
the health care was not great
particularly and not necessarily cheap
when you're when you're on wall street
with a company like that but
uh it was simple in that i knew what i
was getting and then since i've gone to
politics i've now worked for multiple
orgs and campaigns and that sort of
thing so i've had to navigate the system
and worse off manage people who are
navigating the system
and they're asking their boss of
questions and i'm like i yeah i don't
know
so what your book talks about never pay
the first bill uh
highlights all the complexities of what
our system is and how
average people should navigate it so i'm
glad this is what we want to dig into
thank you for being here let's start
though how the heck did you get into
this
um and then you were a reporter you
worked a number of places let's talk a
little bit about
about you and how you got interested in
this topic so
i i actually have kind of an unusual
background for a journalist i started in
full-time ministry
so i did full-time christian ministry
for five years
i went to seminary got a master's degree
in theology
and then i started freelancing and then
i decided to become a full-time
journalist so i sort of am like an
accidental journalist
and but but i look at the world through
a very moral lens i have to say
and and so when i became a reporter i
got really interested in investigative
journalism
and my first five years i covered
you know all the stuff you cover when
you're starting out in journalism
community politics school board meetings
businesses opening
i didn't do that much healthcare
coverage until i went to las vegas at
the las vegas sun
and they asked me to cover healthcare
there and again i knew almost
i knew nothing about it but what i
learned once i started covering
healthcare
is that there are so many schemes
and deceptive practices that are built
into the very legal way that healthcare
is practiced in this country
that if you're a morally minded person
who cares about people
it is a target rich environment for an
investigative reporter i mean
the number of astonishing and outrageous
things that i have uncovered now in the
last 15 years
of covering it it really does
continue to astonish me every day i i
think i keep thinking i won't be
surprised and then i'm i'm more
surprised
we should have probably led with the
fact that you're a moral journalist
because no offense to the journalists
i've had on this podcast before but
that's a bit of an oxymoron at times
specifically i i understand that i i
agree with it but my argument would be
that when journalism is practiced with
integrity genuine truth-telling
with integrity i think it's a very moral
enterprise but of course
you do see things that uh oh yeah i
think honestly
it's like i think it's most and probably
what we'll talk about today
most of life comes down to incentive
most of the problems we're frustrated
with are comes down to incentive
problems where you have
good people incentivized to do slightly
bad things and when they
or just like little selfish things or
whatever it is and then the snowball
grows and grows and actually you know
people are pounding on the bottom people
getting really hurt
that gets at the big problem with
healthcare in the united states
right what is the incentive from the
industry side
the incentive is to make money it's a
profit driven system
and so we have i like to say sometimes
we have the health care system
almost that we deserve as americans
because it really does reflect who we
are
we learn money yeah we love money in the
united states and
and frankly a lot of times what makes
money
is seen as acceptable and so the health
care industry makes a lot of money and
employs a lot of people and so people
might have a hard time saying it's wrong
but the fact is we pay twice as much per
person for health care in this country
than the citizens of any other country
and we're getting much much less in
return
we still have tens of millions of people
who are uninsured
and they say now that one in six
americans has medical debt in
collections
so we're paying twice as much and we're
getting very
very little for our money when you look
at what people pay
it's laughable because this isn't um
i think i've talked about this on the
podcast before there's there's if
if you look at the list of problems like
social problems that are out there um
there's a number of them that like
poverty for example like you could
debate the solutions to that a number of
different ways and we do
um but healthcare to me you go down the
list of all the social problems that are
difficult
but healthcare other countries have
solved for this
which is to me it's like we're doing it
wrong um and i agree it comes down to
worshipping the almighty dollar in this
country
if you make a billion dollars um hurting
people
whether you're making addictive drugs or
frac hurting the environment or
exploiting people or selling their data
we'll put you on the cover of
forbes magazine we'll put you on
whatever it will celebrate you
if you make a billion dollars running
the boys and girls club helping kids all
over the country
we'll crucify you actually if you make
250 000 or a million dollars that's
right
a fraction of that will crucify you so
your book which i um
basically talks all about how people can
beat the system
um or navigate the system where um
almost like navigating the incentives
you're talking about talk to me a little
bit about before we get to the tactics
like let's talk a bit you talk about
incentives but what are you seeing that
was uh
the biggest pain point for people as
they're trying to navigate this stuff
well it's hard to say the number there
are a number of pain points but
they combine to to create
this massive problem for the american
people i mean we've just come through
the pandemic
and yet you and i and everyone we know
has a shared experience almost like we
had this shared experience with covid19
where we have massive headaches with the
system
one of the big problems is the
fragmentation of the system
it's impossible to understand it's all
these siloed entities whether it's drug
companies or
physicians or hospitals or insurance
companies
employers all these self-interested
stakeholders
involved in this incredibly
needlessly complicated system that now
we as individuals are supposed to
somehow navigate
very difficult to navigate the
fragmented system
another big problem it's opaque
it's not transparent we're not told
what the price is before we get a
procedure or before we get a drug
like we would with any other consumer
interaction i mean
imagine if you went down to your
mcdonald's
and you got your burger
and you didn't get a bill until three
weeks later and it was four
you know five times more than you should
have paid for that burger or
imagine if i walk in there with my mom
who's over age 65
she gets the price for the medicare
price for people over age 65 so she pays
three dollars for her big mac
but then me as a working american i get
charged
15 for my big mac which is really
the the the working americans are paying
exponentially more
than medicare patients and that's a
standard
accepted way of doing business but it's
normalized deviance
there's no reason that working americans
should be required to pay
two to five to even ten times more than
a medicare
patient for something like a knee
replacement or an mri
or whatever health care you need it's
it's ridiculous and yet the system has
decided that this cost
shifting where they say well we don't
make enough for medicare
so we're going to shift the cost on to
working americans
that's the standard way of doing
business and i first of all
don't believe that nobody is making
money on medicare i think that is a myth
you know that's we need to actually
investigate that
and then second there's so much waste in
the system
that maybe they need to become more
efficient maybe they need to not be so
bloated with their administration
maybe we need to simplify the way we pay
claims which is wasting hundreds of
billions of dollars a year
so there are other things that we could
do to lower the cost of care
and i think i've just come to the
conclusion zach that
we now have 20 more than 20 years of
data
that shows year by year cost increases
massive spikes in the cost of care that
are being born by working americans
and if the system wanted to change it
could
if our elected officials wanted to
change the system they could do it
i have come to the conclusion that no
one is going to save us
we have got to yeah we have got to stand
up for ourselves
because we've been bullied for so long
and so that's why i wrote the book i
mean the book is called never pay the
first bill and the subtitle
is and other ways to fight the system
and win and i really focus on the
winning part okay
i like i like to win and i think
everybody likes to win and the
and the dirty secret is that for the
insiders who know the industry
they don't interact with the industry in
the same way
they know the hacks they know the
workarounds
they know how to um avoid getting ripped
off
and so with each chapter in the book
i've kind of broken down
how people can follow the advice of
insiders
and what are the how-to tactics to fight
the system and win
i love so many things you just said
because one thing we talk about andrew
and i talked about a lot it's like hey
we've met the leaders we've um both in
the for-profit and the non-profit and
the political space
and the calories not coming it's not and
the other challenge is um the people
that actually have the power
um we have our own challenge we're
distracted
um we're distracted by either working
all day and putting food on the table or
meeting rent or our own health care
issues navigating this system because we
think we have to
or i mean other things entertainment the
the kardashians netflix i mean you know
this this attention economy we are not
paying attention to what i love about
your book and why i wanted you on here
is because
there are things our government needs to
do and i'm excited about that i think
we eventually we have to get there at
some point but if it's not going to fix
itself
or it's not going to fix in the short
term what can you actually
do in the short term and that's where
your book literally lays out like how to
win
so let break this down for me brother
tell me
um i mean i'm assuming this this this
playbook you have if you will starts
after you get the treatment like here's
the bill
time to pay up is that where the journey
begins where your solutions start
helping
walk me through it there's there's
various ways you can look at this so
let's just pretend that you've gotten a
medical bill let's just start with the
title of the book never pay the first
bill i'm not saying never pay your
medical bills
the principle here is never pay the
first bill
until you have analyzed it until you
have scrutinized it
to make sure that it's accurate and
fairly priced because what a lot of
people
don't know is that nobody's actually
looking at these bills
nobody's actually um
analyzing this bill before it gets paid
and before it gets sent on to you
these claims spit out yeah are auto
adjudicated
by a system that's processing millions
of claims a day
spitting things out computers are auto
adjudicating these things
there are strategies that the hospitals
are using
to up code your claims which means they
are inflating
the complexity of the medical codes they
use so that they can charge
more but it's not justified in fact it's
fraudulent
if they're willfully doing that it's
fraudulent the system is also incredibly
sloppy
the number of things that get put onto
people's medical bills that are
wrong totally an error i have talked to
people who review medical bills for a
living who tell me they have seen bills
for patients who receive
two circumcisions i don't think anybody
has ever had
two of those one is enough you know
multiple gallbladder removals on the
same patient on the same day
i mean these are things pregnancy tests
on 82 year old women or on women who've
had hysterectomies
you know so these are things like the
amount of
errors that show up in the bills or
inflated prices or costs
necessitate each of us realizing oh wait
this bill let's assume it's not accurate
before we just assume it's accurate
let's assume it's not accurate
so the first step i tell people is get
an itemized medical bill
the bill from the hospital might say
medical services pharmaceutical services
well what goes into medical services
that's like going to the grocery store
and getting one lump sum bill for all
your groceries
you wouldn't be able to compare the
price of your eggs or your milk or your
cheese and see if you're being cheated
or to make sure like hey why is bread on
my grocery store
receipt i didn't buy bread i'm going to
sell a gluten allergy i never i have a
gluten
right so get an itemized bill it's your
right to have one
and you want that itemized bill to
include the medical billing codes and
now this is going to sound to people
like
totally intimidating i get that but
if you practice some of these tactics
and are willing to learn
just a few basic steps you can save
hundreds or even thousands of dollars
with every health care
interaction i don't know what also is
intimidating thousands of dollars in
health care bills
that's right how about medical debt how
does that feel
so so get an itemized bill if you're if
your hospital won't give you those
billing codes you can get them from the
insurance company and in the book i lay
all this out i explain for people how to
do this
the i the billing codes you can look up
those online
go to google type in medical billing
code with that five-digit billing number
and it will explain what that bill means
when you go
for health care services they create a
medical record
the billers translate the medical record
into a claim that they submit to your
insurance plan or that they turn into a
bill and give to you
you can check your medical records to
see if the care in the record
actually shows up in the bill you can
check to see if the medical record is
accurate so you can also get your
medical records it's your legal right to
have them
it's a good idea to have your records
anyway
so then you can check the bills you can
check prices now
so prices used to be completely blinded
now the federal government requires
hospitals to post their prices
for common procedures is the person i'm
complaining or asking for clarification
to or asking for the price breakdown
is it the billing department
billing department of whatever this and
sometimes it's a third party
it might be a doctor it might be a
hospital whoever it is
you just want you have the right to ask
whoever's sending you the bill
you call the billing department and ask
for an itemized bill
and then if you have questions or you've
identified things that are errors on the
bill
or maybe your insurance company didn't
actually process the bill properly in
fact i got a bill
from an urgent care center where i took
my son last year
the bill came in the mail for 250
dollars it said
amount due 250 responsible party
marshall allen
pay now it had a little thing to put in
your credit card or call
if i was to follow it i would pay it but
i have a
very expensive health insurance plan
that has good benefits in fact i have a
zero deductible plan so
that means that's the amount of money
you have to pay before your plan kicks
in so i knew i was like
man what happened here i called the
insurance company and i said
hey did they submit this bill they said
no it never got
submitted so the bill didn't even get
submitted to my insurance plan
the urgent care just sent me the bill
well i called the urgent care
and i said hi i think you sent me this
bill and error i called my insurance
plan and they said it never got
submitted
the person contested a little bit they
said well we did submit it
i don't think it ever got submitted i
said would you please try and submit it
again
they submitted it again i never saw a
bill for that
so a lot of there's mistakes that happen
at every step of the process
i i had to get five covet tests for my
family i have three kids
i was getting the insurance company
explanation of benefits right the eob
and i explained how to look at eobs as
well
well four of them were fine but you're
not supposed to pay
for covet tests no
i'm free that's the closest thing we've
had to medicare for all that's right
well lo and behold one of the bills
included a charge that was passed on to
me
i i called and inquired why was this
charge passed on to me
for a covet test and they said oh
because the diagnosis on that
the test for your wife was acute
respiratory distress syndrome
which is a really severe
symptom of kovid my wife wasn't
in a civ she had no respiratory issues
with covid she had no problems well
they put the wrong diagnosis code on it
that led to a bill for me
again it was an error i sent it back
they corrected it
and i never saw a bill for that but you
have to assume
that things are an error rather than
rather than assume that these people
know what they're doing
it's chaos out there this is like what i
was talking over time i'm beginning with
incentives if you're the ceo of a
healthcare company
um your job is to maximize profits for
shareholders thank you um
every business school in 1980s and i
guess still today that's the goal
that's right so you're like hey if we
lean six sigma our efficiencies for
those who don't know that is that's when
you like let's
you could take a course on lean six
sigma course and make sure your process
is hyper efficient um no errors or very
smaller margin of error if you don't
do that if you just let it let errors
incentivize errors never double check
the work
that's going to yield five percent of
errors 10 20
that and every time there's an error it
usually means more money for us
and you can model that out you are going
to
intentionally or unintentionally
probably intentionally
maybe not staff up the air department
maybe
never double check the work because
you're going to have you're going to see
more money and it's not
and then you're like well that ceo is a
jerk but the reality is if he doesn't do
that or she doesn't do that sadly it's
statistically probably a he um he's
going to get fired or she's going to get
fired that's what's going to happen the
board will vote them out because they
won't see enough money and that is in
fact
their bonuses depend on profitability
yeah that air rate needs to be high
it's really dark and your point which i
love is like well the best thing you
could either hope the ceo like grows a
conscience or
you can hope our government gets zack
together to stop that or
you can defend yourself and follow the
steps you have in this book
[Music]
hey are you like everybody who has taken
a mental toll
during covid because i have and my
saving grace has been better help and
this episode of yank speaks is sponsored
by
better help and what is better help it
is professional counseling done
privately securely
and simply online if you go to
betterhelp's website you get matched on
a very convenient website that you can
start communicating with professional
counselor in under 48 hours it's not a
crisis line it's not even self-help it's
just professional counseling
done securely online so you can talk
about whether you're depressed or you're
stressed you're
anxious you have relationship issues or
you're not sleeping well or
you're angry for me it's about direction
and i call it my steam valve i just blow
off some steam
once a week and it's freaking fantastic
it's all confidential it's convenient
it's professional it's affordable
i'm a big big big believer in this it's
time to
stop just like tiptoeing around the fact
that we all need someone to talk to
so listen up i want you to start living
a happier life today and as a listener
to yank speaks you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com yang so join over
one million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health that's betterhelp.com
yang
the big question then is okay so you've
identified an overcharge
or an inaccurate charge or you've
identified in fact i helped to
um i've now made this my hobby
to start helping people with their
medical bills
and i've even started now a side
business that i'm calling allen health
academy
to create a series of videos that are
based on the book
that will train that will train
consumers and employees in these tactics
so that they can be equipped and
empowered to fight back
what do you do then if they won't
correct it right like
sometimes it's easy you know they and
and this is also the thing
nothing is standard here you might it
might sound like a total pain and it
might take you
like for my urgent care bill it took me
about three minutes and i saved 250
it was so easy to fix both those
examples i gave you
it might be easy it might be complicated
they might not respond so i think the
game changer
i have a chapter in the book on how to
defend yourself in small claims court
if you're being overbilled and so let me
give you an example
there's a young woman who i just helped
with her medical bill
a bridge designer here in new jersey she
went to the hospital
got three stitches in her finger and
she um was charged the negotiated
discounted rate was about six thousand
dollars for three stitches about two
thousand dollars per stitch
she got her itemized bill and she could
see that most of the charge came from
one particular service it was the
emergency room exam
they build this thing at what's called a
level three emergency room exam
now because of the federal government's
price transparency rule the hospital has
to have its posted
prices on its website even the negro
negotiated rates for each insurance
company so she could see by looking at
that bill
that the united healthcare negotiated
discounted price
for that exam was fifty eight hundred
dollars
meanwhile the cash rate was two hundred
and fifty six dollars
so in other words if she would have been
uninsured and paid cash
she would have paid 22 times less than
she was required to pay with her
united health care insurance plan
this young woman contested this
they refused to negotiate with her they
refused to change it
she sent i have a copy of a warning
letter to send to a hospital before you
sue them
it's a it's a sample letter people can
plug in their own details
gives them 30 days and if you follow the
process where you've got the medical
bill the itemized bill
you've got your medical records you've
looked up the prices so you can see
whether you're being screwed and just
how badly well then you sue them
in small claims court for the amount
that you're being overbilled
so she sued them in small claims court
and it resulted in
the hospital coming to the table and
settling it with her
for uh for for nothing so i had this
issue essentially with uh
um with a landlord which is obviously a
different system but small claims scored
small claims court in some ways um
but one of the things that the landlord
was able to do was
um mess up my credit for a short period
of time where they went to the credit
agency and they're like well because i
was basically saying you know you didn't
do xyz so i'm not paying you rent until
you do it right like not to get into it
but that was where it was
and um and it's very similar here it's
like well you are charging me this
i'm not paying that so i'm not paying
you anything until we you know you come
to the table whatever you want to do
um but they can go to whatever creditor
and say boom the next thing you know
your credit's down
a couple hundred points or whatever it
is and that can hurt you and other
things what are your thoughts there and
how to handle that or
i think if you show that you're
disputing it they'll they have to put it
down but i'm not sure the answer
that's that's correct but i think the
other key here is this process doesn't
actually take that long
and so usually you won't get to that
stage until you're probably past about
three months
as soon as you get the bill you need to
take a look at it and it doesn't take
long to do this but it
you do have to be intentional and you
have to learn this new skill
you might have to be persistent to make
sure you get the itemized bill
so you can see if you're being screwed
or not and if you're not being screwed
then pay the bill
pay what's fair but if you're being
ripped off then you want to contest it
and you can easily do this within that
three-month time frame
but it's really important to know these
skills in advance so that you know how
to handle it
um so that's that's really what i'm
trying to do is equip people
so they're prepped you make your own
decisions before this happens
they're gouging me by an extra hundred
bucks yeah and so some people might be
like look it's not that big a deal i'll
just pay it
other people might say no i'm gonna
fight this thing yeah everybody
because it's economically prudent right
that's right everybody is in a different
situation but if all of us started
demanding fair treatment in this way
so think of what happens when you sue
them in small claims court
you can do this for about thirty dollars
without an attorney it's very easy
you've already gathered all your
evidence
on their side now they probably need to
hire an attorney at a cost a thousand
dollars in attorney fees
thousands of dollars in attorney's fees
to defend a case that's maybe worth a
few hundred dollars maybe it's worth a
few thousand dollars
what we do when we do that is we we take
the game
out of the playing field where they make
all the rules in their favor
and we bring it into our american
judicial system which is not perfect
but it does allow for small claims court
for consumers to defend themselves
and in a lot of states the limits are
big like we have a branch
of called the special civil branch here
in new jersey where i live
the limit's fifteen thousand dollars in
texas the small claims limit is twenty
thousand dollars
in tennessee it's twenty five thousand i
think that's the highest in the nation
but but so these cl this covers a lot of
medical bills especially the typical
kind of
easy uh episodic maybe a
emergency room care or something like
that so it gives them the incentive they
need in fact another case i just helped
a friend of mine at my church had a
dispute with their dentist
where the dentist overcharged them by
about three hundred dollars
because he didn't run it through their
insurance plan the way he should have
they fought that dentist for years they
argued with him they called the biller
hey they got the run around it's much
easier actually
to go you can do it all online by the
way file the case online
the the dentist got served with a
lawsuit
they got a call from the dentist's
attorney a few weeks later
once he had been served and they got a
check
they settled it right away they didn't
want to go to that hearing and have to
deal with all that nonsense
so i it changes the leverage so what i'm
trying to do is show people here's the
leverage we have and by the way
employers have huge leverage that they
have not even started using so
i have eight chapters in the book that
are focused on what individuals can do
looking at different scenarios where you
need some people need
advice and then i have three chapters
for employers and i think employers are
really the sleeping giant in all this
health care reform health care reform
battle
employers have been passively passing
this cost on to their employees that's
what's been happening over the past
decades
it's now become so um unbearable
and shameful that that everybody knows
it
because everyday working americans just
can't even afford these deductibles and
high
premiums that they're being forced to
pay so
i think that if employers and employees
could get on the same page and realize
how much of their money is being
unjustly burned and wasted and
squandered by our health care system
we have what they need to survive they
need
our money if they don't have our money
they've got nothing
and so what we need to do is identify
there's price variation
for every product in every market find
the people who are giving you the low
price the fair price
and reward them with your business and
if somebody is charging you a high price
don't give them your business it's
really as simple as that and once
once we start you know you're seeing
that now where more
employers who are self-funded are
entering into direct contracts with
primary care doctors or even with
specialists you see like walmart has
their centers of excellence plan
where if you need a knee replacement say
they say well you can go anywhere you
want but if you go to this center in
your region
that we have a direct pay relationship
with
we'll waive all your copays all your
deductibles all your cost sharing
and you'll get that paid for 100 percent
by the employer sponsored health
benefits plan nothing out of your pocket
the quality is actually going to be
better
and the care is going to be a lot
cheaper and so you see more
progressively minded employers
creating these different models and i
think that really is the future of where
we're going and where we need to go
there can be debates i feel like
medicare for all
is like a political football that people
like to kick back and forth
use as a talking point to rile up their
base
but the difficulty of putting something
in place like that
i mean the obstacles would have to be
overcome are absolutely enormous
whereas what we can do right now is
employers
and employees can get on the same page
they can see how they
they've been exploited and they can
start
going to the people who treat them
fairly and
shunning the ones that don't and
sometimes the ones that don't treat us
fairly are the big brand name
marquee insurance companies and medical
facilities
those frankly are some of the worst
offenders and we need to
shun them yeah andrew and i've talked a
lot we don't i don't love the concept of
your health care being tied to your
employment i think that
in the 21st century economy that stop it
makes less and less sense over and over
the more you the more you unpack you
peel back that onion
um but it is a competitive
differentiator for employees
or for employers to say hey you come
work here
like your healthcare's covered uh we got
your back um
and like and good companies do that um
yeah but let me let me just point out
something here i mean i'm trying to
reframe the way we think about this
stuff
because there's even a myth of this idea
of rich health benefits right
because all of that money that the
employer
is paying in health benefits belongs to
the employee
in the form of the employee compensation
oh you're saying you're paying too much
and it should be going to the person
yeah
that's just taking more money out of
your wages so these rich health benefits
that all the white-collar workers get
touched
they're they're they're being fooled
this is how the system wants you to
think about it oh your employer is
paying
no you're the one paying for this you're
right the employer is funding
the compensation and then we're
compensated through our wages
our health benefits our paid time off
our maybe a
hopefully a retirement plan contribution
so that's our benefits package
that is our pool of compensation
but 100 of the money once the employer
funds our health benefits
that all belongs to the employee and i
compare this to like your employer
taking you out saying hey i want to take
you out to a fancy restaurant let's go
out for dinner
so you go to this five-star place your
employer says order whatever you want
it's on
it's on me you're like great so you know
you're getting the steak you're getting
the flambe dessert you know
wine well they they bring the check and
they put it on the table
and your employer reaches into your
wallet and pulls out your credit card
and pays the bill
that's what it's like when you have rich
health benefits
that are supposedly paid for by your
employer it's not paid for by your
employer folks it's coming out of your
compensation
and so then there's less money available
to pay you wages
and if you look at the studies that have
been done it shows
wage wages are stagnant in the united
states over the last two decades in
large part
because health care costs are consuming
employee compensation at an unreasonable
rate fascinating and that's right
because i pay depending on the company
we've run it's 500 to a thousand bucks a
month
per employee and you can get scale on
that you can
dial up dial down the benefits um
but and in most cases what i just talked
about let's say i land at 750
an employee right in the middle there
the employee still has to pay for crap
like it doesn't even fully so now only
taking 750 bucks a month from you the
employee but also you're still stuck
with
um whatever the difference is in your
actual medical bills it's a mess
okay this episode of yankspeaks is
sponsored by athletic greens i just had
this
i have this little awesome athletic
greens bowl i put my athletic green
powder in it i take a scoop every
morning put it in some water
mix it up it tastes delicious and it's
very good for you
it's got 75 vitamins minerals whole food
source ingredients
including a multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend and more
and they all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet increase
your energy and focus
and help with digestion and immune
system and everything you need
in one powder instead of multiple
products so here's the deal
simply visit athleticgreens.com yang and
join health experts athletes and health
conscious go-getters around the world to
make a daily commitment
to their health every day and if you do
it now they're offering our audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs which i do
love so
visit athleticgreens.com get your free
year supply of vitamin d and five free
travel packs
today
your book talked about this your website
eventually have advice for people to
start to navigate this i love the advice
on how to go to small claims court
because that sounds daunting like a pain
in the butt
and it's probably not i mean it's time
consuming right but it's if done well i
mean a lot of judges
um when it's the the small human versus
the big company they're inclined in that
type of court to side with the human
um especially if there's someone who
probably takes the time to read your
book
and knows their stuff if you will um
another thing you say in your book is um
talk about making friends with your debt
collector um
how does that work because that's like i
don't know maybe it's
like the you know you're you're in
ministry like i think in back
in like biblical terms it's like we
don't like the debt collectors or
whatever it was i mean maybe jesus did
but
that's right the tax collectors are the
worst right
yeah the the i would say the debt
collector is the modern day tax
collector
um scorned you know the the uh
the parasite on yeah right
yeah so so so i think the thing is is
that i talked
for this chapter so in each chapter i
tried to feature an expert
who could be like a guide into this
world to help us
to show us how to win right i don't know
personally i've
i thankfully have not had medical debt
thankfully
and so i haven't had to encounter this
myself but i talked to jerry ashton
who founded the charity rip medical debt
and what
he used to be a debt collector for
decades in health care
and so jerry knows the ins and the outs
of the industry and that led him to
start this charity that actually buys
people's medical debt and forgives it
so i asked jerry what's the right
approach here how do you handle this
and he explained again medical debt like
your medical bills
you don't want to avoid it when the
medical debt collector calls you
in fact the first thing you want to do
is dispute the debt in writing
immediately even if you think oh i did
go to that doctor i went to that
hospital
dispute it in writing make them prove
that they're the ones that own the debt
that they're the ones that are justified
to collect for it
also i would assume that any medical
debt that's out there
is based on erroneous bills and jacked
up
unfair prices because that's the
standard in the industry
so i would not assume personally that
any medical debt
is as a result of just somebody
not paying an honest bill um i and so
it's also i think one of the just great
shames of our country that we have this
problem
but the the point is you have to
negotiate with that medical debt
collector
to get out from under the debt let's say
it's a legitimate debt
you're going to dispute it but let's say
you're going to come to a you need to
come to an agreement i like to use the
term
we need to come to an agreement that
works well for both of us so when you're
talking to that medical debt collector
you need to understand
how much money can that debt collector
get from you
and still be seen as a winner in his
box's eyes
i did i won hey boss i won for you i
collected
and the surprising thing is what jerry
told me is
if your debt gets sold to a debt buyer
it was probably sold for pennies on the
dollar he said maybe a nickel on the
dollar at the most
so therefore if you owe a thousand
dollars
the hospital says you have a thousand it
would have been sold to a debt collector
for
f what's what's 5 50 bucks
in other words if you pay more than 50
to that debt buyer
they're profiting so i asked jerry
what's
what do you think is the range the ratio
of discount that you think
would make the met the debt buyer and
debt collector
feel like they got a win he said
probably 15
so let's say you're going to try and get
that thousand dollars you owe down to 15
this all comes now down to negotiation
right i'm sure you've done a lot of
negotiating i've done some negotiating
in my
time i love that
process but it doesn't help to have it
be hostile
and confrontational so you're going to
want to cuss that debt collector out
you're going to want to tell them how
unfair it is that they're coming after
you
what a scumbag they are to be in in the
business they're
doing i mean you're going to maybe want
to say all those things
but what if you said hey look i would
really love to pay you this
the problem is i don't have the money
and unless you can give me
a massive discount i am
um not gonna be able to pay anything to
you and you're just gonna take an l on
this one
so what tell me let's let's talk
let me tell you about my family i got
bills you know have them get to know you
get to know them as a human being
and then if you do come to an agreement
jerry's other big piece of advice is
do not ever enter an agreement with a
medical debt collector that you won't be
able to
stay true to because if you violate that
agreement even once you miss one payment
on a payment plan
they will come after you then for the
entire amount
it's the whole thing so just hold them
off your credit's already
hurt because of the medical debt hold
them off make them think they're not
going to get anything
unless they get a great deal from you be
the friendliest person they've ever met
so that you know they actually want to
give you a good deal it's amazing how
much
you know more bees with honey whenever
more bees with honey right so
i think that's really good advice it's
counter intuitive but but it makes of
course because you wanna you're so mad
um because i dealt this is i had this
with basically a rent dispute and
everybody i talked to in writing from
the management company was like you owe
this much you have this much i'm not
paying that much i don't wanna go to
court over this but i'm not paying that
much it's ridiculous
um but once i finally got to
the end player like the final boss
whatever you want to call it who's like
who's like i'm like i finally got my
phone like look i'll be real with you
like you don't want to go a court over
this
i don't want to deal with this crap
anymore like this is what i think is
fair
and what i owe and this gives you money
now that either if i go to court i think
i'm gonna win
maybe you do who knows um but even then
you're gonna have legal fees you're not
gonna get it all what do you think he's
like great
can you send it over today yes done
period yeah
and if you're paying a lump sum right
now you're going to get a discount on
that
discount which i did that's right and
your what your book is teaching which i
love is hey
this is an art it's not science stand up
for yourself you have more power than
you think
um and you're getting deceived
um in terms of because i think a lot of
us get that fear you get that bill
you're like oh crap i owe this and then
you're like how am i gonna pay for how
am i gonna pay for how am i gonna figure
it out
and the reality is you're saying pump
the brakes
that may not be what you owe man be
close to what you owe it could actually
be an error
um that's right make them make them
verify it make them prove it and if
you're getting screwed
don't back down i mean i think the other
thing
you know maybe from my ministry
background i look at this as a moral
issue
and i frame it as a moral argument but
there is incredible
moral force behind the truth of one
person's story
and it's kind of like how in a movie you
know when there's that scene where the
person's getting bullied
by the big bad bully and everybody can
identify with that right but when that
person then stands up to the bully and
wins
it's not because they're more powerful
or stronger than the bully not usually
it's usually because they have what's
right on their side and as patients
we have the moral high ground here we're
the victim here
and what and we need to speak up and and
call folks
out and make them justify the unjust
things they're doing
which they won't be able to do make them
prove
that we owe what they claim we owe which
often they won't be able to do
and then refuse to pay it but but not
not because we're not paying bills that
are fair
but because we're saying you don't have
a right to exploit my sickness for
profit
you're not entitled to just take as much
money from me as you want
that's not okay and when we stand up for
ourselves in that way there's moral
force just in us
asserting what's true right one of the
few things that actually scales is truth
and um and facts um so to your point
like
this is it is is sometimes a painful
fight sometimes it's
it's um there's a lot of labor involved
it's complicated annoying but
you should win it because you should
have you realistically have facts on
your side if someone is profiting off of
something you cannot control
yeah let me let me give you a few other
topics here where it's really important
if you know how things
work it's actually easy to save a lot of
money
one example is avoiding unnecessary care
i have a friend named jeff i often have
people call me and ask me to help them
find a doctor you know because i've done
a lot of reporting on patient safety
issues
quality of care issues anyway jeff had a
lot of spine pain and
thought he needed a spinal surgery so i
helped him find a couple doctors
but i also told him you know jeff many
back surgeries are unnecessary and can
be treated with physical therapy
lifestyle changes so look into that too
just be aware
that you might not need back surgery
well he went to a
spinal surgeon and the spinal surgeon
told him this is an emergency we need to
operate right now
if you go out and play golf you could be
paralyzed
jeff went to another spine surgeon the
other guy also he didn't he wasn't quite
as dire but he recommended definitely i
think we need to operate
well jeff wasn't quite comfortable with
that he thought he'd give it some time
he went to physical therapy
six sessions he learned some exercises
he could do at home
he changed his diet he changed the way
he did his martial arts training to tone
it down a little bit
and the back pain went away and he had
no problem
and now he just shakes his head thinking
about how much it would have cost him
and how much harm it would have caused
him if he would have had a spinal fusion
or some other type of spinal surgery
so we can save a lot of money just by
avoiding care we don't need
and so the number one question i always
recommend people
ask their doctor or nurse practitioner
or whoever
when they're offering you something
that's like a discretionary
procedure or test or drug ask them this
question
ask them hey what happens if we wait
what's the worst thing that could happen
to me if we don't proceed with this
right now
make them articulate that for you find
out what the options are if you take a
minute
research it some more go home obviously
we're not talking about an emergency
case or a trauma case or a case where
you have confirmed cancer that needs to
be treated we're talking about
discretionary care
and most medical care is discretionary
so find out what happens if we wait make
them frame it that way and then we can
avoid unnecessary care
i love that i'm a big believer in second
opinions i've had certain doctors tell
me yeah
i'm like hey my stomach hurts on xyz
that one will say you need surgery and
the other says just here five foods to
avoid
and like the difference and you're like
all right maybe i'll get a third or
fourth opinion because you guys are all
over the map
and um you know plenty of insurance
companies have a network of doctors they
don't need to be world-class you just go
and you
set up appointment when you're free um
so
or even someone will do on the phone do
it now with with in covet let him do
virtually so
um i love that because
there's some sort of it and it's
frustrating
and you probably feel this we all want
to trust our doctor
you know there's a desire you go in like
doc
tell me what's wrong um and
there's a couple problems there one um
they are human
like us and two to our point earlier
their incentives aren't always aligned
with yours many times
it's more procedures and treatments even
if they're honest they're like yeah yeah
you know i get paid for this it's
probably yeah that's right
and it's for them it's what you kill
you know they get paid by the procedure
and so they're incentivized that way
yeah so um so how can um
if people want to find your book find
you is it marshallallen.com where can
people go
the books available on amazon barnes and
noble
anywhere books are sold um i have a
penguin random house as a publisher and
they've done an amazing job getting the
book out there
the you for more information about me or
my curriculum if people are interested
in that
for more health literacy go to
marshallallen.com and people can sign up
for my newsletter
learn more about me and the work i'm
doing um
i'm really excited zach i mean i wrote i
wrote this book because
i i have done 15 years of careful
investigating of the system
on behalf of the public and nobody's
paid me
to have a particular opinion i love
propublica because
they let me do deep dives i mean the
stories i do for propublica
take months each of them yeah and so
rare in journalism
it's so rare it's so rare and they're
genuinely interested in me doing these
stories on behalf of the public
and so i don't write about health care
from the point of view of what's good
for the hospitals or for the economy
or for employment or for shareholders i
write about it from the point of view of
the patients
and this book really was a privilege
because it allowed me to take 15 years
of what i've
learned and add add more of my
personality to it
and more kind of how-to tactics about
what to do about these things
and i really think i really hope it will
empower and equip people
to not become victimized by the system
there's a certain wholesomeness and real
life superhero aspect to what you're
doing so
thank you for doing what you're doing
because you're um it's very it's very
much aligned with
kind of humanity first concept it is
about you and helping the people and
you're talking about
where it hits at the ground level where
this system
the rubber meets the road and that's
where most of the pain is so
i'm excited i i mean look if millions of
people read your book millions people
will get help that's like the reality of
how
simple and straightforward and
practically tactical this book is so
much people thank you yeah
thank you if people put these tactics
into place they can save hundreds or
thousands of dollars with every
healthcare interaction
and they will flip the system upside
down the system will have to respond if
people get engaged
that's the and that is the real takeaway
that's across anything if people start
caring more
things will start to change until that's
right you know or uh we're gonna be it's
probably
just gonna keep him worse so marshall
thank you
um you guys can pick up the book we'll
have the link
never pay the first bill seriously don't
pay the first bill ask
do your homework guys um i hope no one
gets stuck with crazy medical bills
and with that thank you for joining the
future of it's great to be with you
marshall
thanks zack
[Music]
you